- We've been celebrating
World Teachers' Day
with an audience full of educators.
I wanna close out with one
more story for our teachers.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music sting)
More than 90% of teachers
say they have to dig
into their own pockets to cover the cost
of school supplies in their classrooms.
One non-profit in North Carolina
is alleviating that burden
on teachers in disadvantaged communities.
For 20 years, Classroom
Central has run a shop
where teachers can come and
load up on supplies for free.
We have the founding executive director
on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to Karen.
(audience cheering)
Hi, Karen.
- Hey, Kelly.
- Oh my God, this is so cool.
So, the teachers still get to shop,
they just don't have to pay, right?
- That's right. So, we're set up just like
any other retail operation would be.
The only difference is we
don't have any cash registers.
Everything is available
100% free of charge.
And as you can imagine,
teachers get really excited-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- About the opportunity
to come and shop with us.
Our free store is stocked
with everything that you can imagine.
Books, and backpacks,
and incentives to motivate
and reward students.
And, of course, we have
all the basic supplies
like pencils, and
crayons, and glue sticks.
Really, everything that you can imagine
having in a backpack or a classroom.
- This is just the coolest
thing ever, you have no idea.
Like my mother really could have used this
'cause we didn't have money
and she used to use ours that
we didn't have to do that.
And- and that's what a
lot of you probably do
and it's a really cool thing.
So where do you get the supplies from?
- Yeah, so most of the
supplies are donated through-
we have supply drives that
take place in the summer,
but we also have just
organizations that are collecting
for us year-round,
businesses that make or manufacture goods
that are giving those to us
periodically throughout the year.
And we also, since we're a nonprofit,
we have folks that
contribute to us financially
and we use a portion of that
money to go out and buy things.
I mean, we can't have a
free school supply store
if we don't have pencils.
So oftentimes, when we're running low,
we'll go and we'll actually
buy those materials.
And so, it's really because
of our amazing community
that has been supporting
us for almost 20 years-
- [Kelly] Wow.
- That we've been able to give away
$80 million worth of free school supplies.
- Wow.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Oh my God, congratulations.
That's- that's incredible. All
those people you're helping.
Thank you so much, Karen.
I'm liking your post right now.
(ding)
And that's not all,
our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like Classroom Central,
so they're giving your
not-for-profit $1,000.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Dr. Jill Biden, LeVar
Burton, Kirsten, and Justin,
and just a huge thank you
to each and every teacher
here and watching at home.
I know some days get really tough,
but you are doing angels'
work and you are appreciated.
Trust. Have a great day y'all.
And if it's not, try and change it.